there's
all evidence that they were these big
ones were tombs some of them were used
later on undoubtedly as tombs and
repurposed that way but not these ones
the big ones I don't even think the
domestic Egyptians got into them frankly
I I think they couldn't get into them
we'd see a lot more evidence of it if
they were if they did you don't think
they could because of just the sand like
just blockages I mean you've got to
imagine like when these things were
covered in the in the the casing Stones
it's like it's super white it would have
like reflected the sun like a mirror and
there's no visible joins it's you cannot
pry those stones out there's no obvious
entrance to it you know it's just it's
it's really difficult to look at that
the very the top of the middle one still
has some of those casing stones that are
weathered over time but yeah can you
imagine these just perfect
pyramids they're just like I know does
it need some giant triangles if it's not
a tomb what would you conjecture is the
purpose I think I personally my and it's
speculation I think they were functional
I think they was they they did something
I think they're all broken now they
don't work anymore I think they were a
functional device what that is I don't
know there's lots of theories out there
a guy named Chris Dunn a good friend of
mine a very good author engineer he's
really has moved this whole
um uh field forward in a lot of ways
when it comes to ancient precision and
Technology yeah he has a theory that
it's like the Giza power plant it does
explain his theory does explain all of
the elements of the pyramid he used it
to correctly predict what was behind
gate and brings door which is one of
those little things in one of the shafts
in uh in the Great Pyramid can you
explain this to us yeah so so in the
there's really weird aspects these are
not functional by the way these are your
bracelets yeah yeah I clang them
together
exactly dynastic exemptions did not get
it dude yeah the ancient Civ one looks
great though yeah they understand
visuals for sure yeah they did okay yeah
so gain brings door well there's these
strange features in there right you've
got so we're inside the Great Pyramid so
you go in there's three chambers right
there's a Subterranean chamber that's
down way below it in the Bedrock with a
shaft that goes through the the pyramid
can we access that because I don't think
I went I went inside I don't know if I
went down so not unless you do like a
special permission every time I we rent
it out for two hours they open a lot for
us oh wow so if you're going on a
tourist ticket you can go into like the
grand gallery and up into the king's
chamber yeah that's where most people go
yeah there's also a chamber below that
called the Queen's chamber now those
both the Kings the so-called King and
queen's chamber have these shafts right
so there's the ones in the king's
chamber go to the outside we know this
because at some point you know some of
these crazy British guys were rolling
cannonballs down them and they ended up
in the king's chamber like ah that
connects oh wow so they just found
cannonballs in the Tomb and they were
like well they were just like there's an
opening we think it might be on their
shot let's Finance
I mean there's rods there's explorations
of these shafts there's like big long
steel rods that have tried to probe them
with but the ones in the Queen's chamber
are more interesting because they don't
go to the outside they terminate
somewhere inside the structure now this
is like a
four to six inch square shaft right
is this big
it's how the hell do you make that it
has to be made when you're building the
structure like it has to be planned we
don't know where they go but we
eventually we sent robots down them
and it turns out they go to what looks
like a little door there's a little door
at the end it's a it's a limestone plug
and it looks like it's got if you go to
like gate and Brick's door uh maybe
there's pictures of that I don't know
but maybe this gate and yeah that's it
there well that's after they drilled
through it so that actually and on the
door of these two what they say a copper
copper uh handles but one of them's
eroded more than the other it's almost
like it's an anode cathode like it may
have been part of some sort of function
like a [__] battery yeah something
like that so part of Chris Dunn's Theory
yeah that's it there so you had this is
what's at the end of this of this shaft
get the [__] out yeah and then yeah
eventually
yeah it's like a soccer well those are
little copper things that are on there a
bit no the whole they they they drilled
okay they see the drill bit there yeah
so Chris Dunn anyway so he's he he
explains all of these features of the
pyramid in his Giza power plant Theory
and using his theory before they drilled
through the hole he said what they're
going to find is another void and
another little door and they drilled
through the hall they drilled through
this wall and guess what they found
another void
yeah holy [__] so I think he was onto
something
um and again it lines up with your
theory it's too advanced for it not to
be functional yeah there's no per
there's no people say like oh this is
where the soul would have escaped and
gone up towards like this this is
nonsense
building a pyramid just in that shape is
the most functional to build this is a
functional thing that's why we're going
to build it in a pyramid shape 100 yeah
that is [__] and they haven't drilled
battery Theory they didn't drill past
the second door no as far as well so no
there's a God yeah there's a lot of
nonsense going on about this for a long
time like gate and Brink sent his robot
up the wrong shaft as well we went and
had a look in there and say he was threw
him out of Egypt and it so there's been
a lot of intrigue there's a this there's
a ducks like there's all sorts of
stories when you dive into egyptology in
particular in the last let's say 30 40
Years of what's going on in these
pyramids and and on these sites and
about who's done what where is a lot of
stories that all revolve around certain
particular characters that have been in
charge of some Antiquities departments
can you um speak to the politics of why
you can't start just Excavating more of
these oh it's just
it's it's controlled by the uh the
Council of Antiquities used to be called
the Supreme Council of Antiquities in
Egypt and for a long time a guy named
Zahir was was in charge of that and this
is you know this comes back to the
Labyrinth story as well that we we
mentioned before
um or we talked about before and you
know he has he they really tightly
control what goes on on the sites right
so you can't just roll up there and say
Hey I want to dig
um the way that works is you have to you
have to partner with this with this with
the council to do anything and part of
that is also they will want to know what
your purpose is what are you trying to
find and then they get to control the
release of information at the end of it
so typically what happens is you have
institutions like universities from
France or Belgium Austria America
wherever Britain they have access to a
particular site to do research in a
certain way and then that re that that
information is very slowly released
whenever the Egyptian authorities deem
it necessary to do so why are they so
protective of this uh theory of History
why are the people the people who are
kind of claim to fame my boy that's all
they got I guess but to me science is
constantly disproving other science they
don't give a [__] about science they
give [__] about like yo we're Egyptian
these pyramids are fire everybody loves
these pyramids we made them and if this
[__] comes over there and goes nah I
was some other people 30 000 years ago
you just bumped in on it they're like
man shut the [__] up I guess they'll let
you discredit our whole [__] I guess in
my mind they're still Egyptian and it
would still be like yo we survived
[__] apocalypse we came back
we're still here that's a good there's a
good argument to that that but I think
they might look at it like man we didn't
really do [__] since back in the day
it's not it's not even necessarily
Egyptian that's driving this too it's
kind of a mainstream uh egyptology and
Eck and also yeah and also I'm sure
there's a religious component which is
like you know if you're dating the world
yeah you know six thousand years ago and
then you come in and it's fifty thousand
years
it operates a bit like a religion to be
honest and unfortunately there's a lot
of domains of science that suffer from
from that type of embedded you know
Dogma yeah into one extent and it's it
does tie back to these essentially
what's history right it's it's a it's a
collect it's a story that you Cobble
together from a collection of incomplete
facts now when more new facts come up
and younger driest and all this new
scientific work we should be taking that
into account but
you know there's a the problem arises
when it starts to pull the rug out of
the people that have have really set
what that story is and it honestly the
story of history and civilization hasn't
changed for around 100 years it still
hasn't changed even with Gobekli Tepe we
still say well civilization started six
thousand years ago with the Sumerians
then the Egyptians and then the Greeks
and Romans Chinese all this other stuff
yeah
um is there a framework here for how
this could be conducting energy and
power and what that power is used for
Chris Dunn's
um Giza power plant Theory takes into
account all of this stuff I don't I'm
not an expert on it but it's it's like
it's it's it has a lot to do with
Acoustics the grand gallery has a bunch
of these heimholtz resonators in it it's
a really interesting Theory there's
there's like different fluids and
chemicals used in these shafts there's
there's a lot to it and there's a lot of
evidence for it as well like those
shafts in the Queen's chamber for
example I mean they don't even come out
into the Queen's chamber they terminate
like six inches from the wall so there
was a guy running around like literally
tapping on the wall she's like oh that
sounds a bit different behind there so
whether they get a sledgehammer and they
bust the wall open they find the shafts
like there's nothing and and when they
first found the Queen's chamber by the
way it was covered in like six inches of
these crystals that may have been the
byproduct of some sort of chemical
reaction and in fact there's a I've got
in here actually I shouldn't have gone
in there but they've been doing these
experiments so they unlocked one of
these Gates there's like a shaft and the
little Grotto area that goes in through
because there's this Alcove in the
Queen's chamber but you can go right
into the masonry behind it opens up into
a little Grotto area I crawled in there
and I've filmed and you can still find
chunks of this Crystal all these weird
growths that are because they they
cleaned it a lot and carved it all off
when they when they when they cleaned up
the the inside of the pyramid but
there's a lot of this weird evidence
like something else was going on and
what is his theory as to what this power
could have been used for some form of
energy
I don't know there's some sort of
microwave energy that they could have
used if they had a receiver for it they
could have done it essentially they
think it may be coming from like this
harmonic tone or this generation it
comes from the earth it's yeah it's a
lot of complex theories on I don't know
like I I think his theory is the best
one that we have that that explains it
with our Tech my personal opinion is I
think it it's probably broader than that
I think we don't quite understand what
it's for but I do think it was
functional can you explain this
resonance theory that you shared I think
it was on the concrete podcast that you
did right so yeah I mean just one thing
you find when you go in and you would
have found this when you went into the
Kingstown like it's insanely resonant
right it's just like this the the
Acoustics in there are off the charts
yeah and
there's you know but it could be
coincidence it's also very underwhelming
which makes me feel like it wasn't a
chamber the chamber the chamber itself
you're in there you're like oh this is
just like the the awe-inspiring view of
the pyramids on the outside and then you
get into this king's chamber right yeah
it's a box it's a box yeah so this is
made up of like 70 ton Granite monolith
there's no question like like the the
feet in order to execute placing these
70-ton Granite blocks around it is very
special but when you look at the
grandiosity of like the dynastic Dynasty
Egyptians it's not reflected in this
room in any way and if that was the
King's Room like for a king that I think
would be a little different it makes way
more sense to me that this is a power
Factory yes that looks like the source
of the power or the batteries hooked up
or whatever it is that to me makes way
more sense because if I'm the king and
that's the room you made me you're dead
do we know Brandon here [__] I
need more [__] yeah
do we know if Granite has any functional
properties that could be yeah it's
piezoelectric it's a conductor a
piezoelectric if you hit it with enough
pressure it generates electricity uh
there's a lot of quartz content in the
granite I've done experiments with guys
we've actually seen different electrical
conductivity properties between Granite
Basalt and Limestone they have different
properties so you see these types of
stones uh lined up and and sites made of
these different types of stones that
have these different electromagnetic
properties to them I think there's
possibilities I think that's where we
should be experimenting and doing work
to try and figure it out does it make
are is there evidence of cities close to
every one of these pyramids because that
makes sense that if it's the power plant
for the city right but if they're just
out there in the middle of nowhere and
there's no City around it then it
doesn't the power plant Theory kind of
like goes away we don't know the city's
probably built on top of the remnants of
older cities I mean you see this Cusco
in other places too yeah I mean those so
each of those pure Germans that's the
interesting thing about those pyramid
thoughts is that they are all I call
them like the Sun Belt you from each one
you can see the next one so starting up
at Abra wash up on the hill you can see
Geezer then you can look down to see you
know abuser to Sakara to dashur and you
see each other on the on the horizon so
I mean I I don't know maybe they're all
connected there's been rumors of
underground infrastructure in between
these sites I've heard that story the
[__] out yeah connecting all the
potentially I've heard that story I
don't make sense functionally if you
need to power the whole city or whatever
yeah something's so Monumental as the
Pyramids of Giza and the fact that
perhaps maybe other people built them
and then they were discovered by new
people and then those people died out
and discovered by new people why was it
eventually just left so Barren for so
long
well it was it was it was used as a
quarry eventually it's like you know
what you know what's easier than digging
up Stone from the ground taking the
Stone from this damn thing yeah it's
just a sourcing place for stuff yep it
was like yeah there was there were
sources of quarries people would just
take Stone from it like people lived
like up until
mono that's probably less than 100 years
ago people lived at these sites in Egypt
the temples the pyramid places before
they became these tourist attractions
people would like pitch their tents and
tie their they'd cut holes in the stone
to tie the camels up donkeys or whatever
and they'd live there and the same as
all the temples people just live there
turned into markets I mean we blackened
the ceilings of these temples from cook
fires oh really generations and then
eventually the government came along and
says you know what you guys get all the
F out we're going to turn these into
tourist attractions so in some ways like
we've inherited them these sites today
we use them as tourist attractions we've
renovated them you would think that the
neighborhood Egyptians did the same
thing around the pyramids would be like
Central Park property you know what I
mean like it is not like there are
people out there who probably live in
like really like lower income homes that
have a perfect view of the most amazing
thing that humans have ever created my
body Yusuf lives in nazlet al-samam
which is the Village near the Sphinx
entrance and he's got his shop there and
his little Balcones on the fifth floor
of this building yeah and we sit out
there and play music or whatever and
just stare right at the Sphinx and the
pyramids like that's the view he grew up
with it's insane wow yeah it is cool and
they're trying to knock it all down now
the government wants to go and want to
build hotels
yeah but it is really interesting so it
must have been like so normalized to
them that they wouldn't try to build
around it that's what's peculiar to me I
you know it's a roof over people's heads
in a lot of places and these
particularly the temples man they just
they just and they would don't care and
they'd cut holes in it and they'd take a
lot of people would scoop out and get a
blade and scoop out material and take it
as some sort of you know healing powder
or whatever you're taking a piece from
the gods and stuff like that so right
but the people that actually build us
that how advanced they were there's no
necessarily a theory as to why they went
away or why they left or were they
killed or I don't know I mean the
stories they tell was cataclysm
let's put it this way so the Egyptians
themselves I don't think you can
separate the domestic Egyptians from the
what you might call a build to build a
culture right the advanced culture the
Egyptians themselves call themselves a
legacy culture so they they describe two
time periods before the dynastic
civilization the oldest one is called
zeptepi it's when the gods themselves
walk to the Earth they had mystical
capabilities it went for like like 25
000 years yeah they it's like they those
were the gods that then get worshiped as
gods in their Pantheon they supposedly
walk the earth this is Horus
yep and then after they went away for
whatever reason there's a Time called
the shimsu [__] or the followers of
Horus again these semi-divine mystical
beings with all of these crazy powers
that you could interpret as magic or
technology and they Reign for like 15
000 years or something as disciples and
well yeah they have these Kings lists of
these rulers that then it adds up to
like 15 000 years for the shimsu horror
and like 25 000 years for zept happy and
then menes is the first king of the
first dynasty and it goes right on
they look at that that's our history and
it's it's our academics that decide you
know what men is that's actually where
the history starts and before that's all
myth and the Egyptians themselves didn't
make that decision now let's assume
there's a cataclysm
yeah happens tomorrow God forbid
a thousand years from now
and it brings us back to Hunter gather a
thousand years from now if people were
telling stories about these ancient
humans that had little blocks that they
could see
we would sound like the gods you would
it would sound like the gods to people
thousands of years to people across the
planet in one second on a not even yeah
through the air you know what the idea
of a satellite is so foreign it
literally seems like we're just sending
messages
in space that could track people at any
point you could have a self-automated
weapon that would kill while one person
sounds like the craziest thing the angry
gods that would strike down the wicked
yeah it's and you might even imitate you
might find a black Shiny Rock and carve
it to look like that and try and do it
and that's I think what's happened in
ancient Egypt because across these these
categories of artifacts and objects you
see like A Tale of Two Industries you
have the you have the advanced objects
and then you have the Primitive objects
that match the Primitive tools so I
think there was a lot of imitation and
replication going on I think a lot of
these places like these ancient sites
the Old Kingdom sites the pyramid sites
eventually became ceremonial sites by
the ancient Egyptians they were they
were the ones dancing around the
campfires trying to turn them on again
because they've got some cultural memory
of something happening
we would do the same thing it's human
nature how do we get this no this is
still Egyptians